what is the labor theory of value and
actually before that yeah what is value
is that um this is like me asking what's
happiness
uh is there something interesting to say
about trying to define value you vary
and this is a huge problem in economics
is arguments of what does value mean
and the neoclassicals came down and said
it's subjective
its
value is whatever you get out of it it's
your personal
evaluation of something your personal
feelings so they've got that very
subjective idea of value whereas the
marxists and the being inheritors of
classical school
talk in terms of objective value so the
value is the number of hours it takes to
make something
or the effort the value is value is the
effort that goes into making something
in the classical score well that's just
one measure of objective where do you
fall
where do you fall i feel
objective versus
subjective versus objective spectrum i
think you have to you have to have the
capacity to to move between one and the
other in a structured model of value
yeah my base model is the objective okay
but above that as soon as you start
talking you did about the worker for
example
then you get involved in subjectivity
because a worker will be angry
and justifiably so about being treated
as a commodity because i'm not i'm not a
commodity i'm a human being okay and
that's
where marx saw political organization
coming from
so and that's subjective now and then
when you get to money itself marx
actually said well what's the price
what's the value of money
now if you use an objective theory of
value you would say oh the cost of money
the value of money is its cost of
production what's the cost of producing
a dollar it's about two cents
so he said it can't be
the value of money cannot be its cost of
production
or the most value i think if you
remember the phrase properly almost is
value here as it must mean the
effectively
uncertain expectations or subjective
valuation
uncertain expectation or subjective
evaluation okay but he's okay with that
he was okay with that because he could
move between different levels because he
had a structured foundation of this
dialectical vision okay if foreground
background tension
uh commodity having used value exchange
value and a gap between the two
when you're talking about
machines when you're buying stuff for
production
and then
at the next level you could look at
workers worker organization and say
that's driven by being treated as a
commodity when you're a non-commodity so
the basic uh
labor theory of value
that is described to karl marx is that
value at the base layer fundamentally
comes from
the labor you put into something yeah
and
you say well there's some deep truth
there except he misses one fundamental
point which is machines can
also bring value to the world he was
saying they don't
he what he was
the only thing that matters is human
labor
not
not labor how do you measure what's the
role
of the uh whatever value machines bring
together okay
this is
this is another intriguing history
because
marx when he first started had what you
can call a uh
an exclusivist explanation for why labor
created value
and that was to say that uh there's the
labor is the only commodity
with both what he called commodity and
commodity power
so you have
labor and labor power
labor is the
and i get fuzzy about this i haven't
read it for something like 30 years but
labor has both commodity and commodity
power the commodity is you can buy labor
which is the means of subsistence labor
powers the capacity to work inside a
factory
there's a difference between the two
therefore that difference will give rise
to surplus and there's no other
commodity that has this incidence of
commodity and commodity power so that
was his exclusivist argument in the
middle of the 1857
he was
visited by a guy called otto brow
in his home in chelsea
and otto returned to marx a copy of
of hegel's phenomena i think it's called
phenomenology of wright i haven't read
it but that's the book and
marx was then at this stage reading
through all the classical theorists
again
and he was
suddenly he read hegel again and if you
know hunter s thompson
okay
somebody who hasn't had enough drugs
obviously yeah but hunter is thompson he
comes to you in a dream after you take
your first masculine or whatever and you
can of course move on if you know your
drugs well enough you can tell okay
stoned okays on cocaine you know well
mark suddenly his writing style in the
middle of a book called the grundrisa
completely changed he switched from weed
to cocaine he switched from ricardo to
hegel okay and what in ricardo he had
this exclusivist argument about labor
and suddenly hegel is back talking in
terms of dialectics not actually using
the word but foreground and background
and tension
and then he that's where this use value
exchange value attention thing came from
is re-reading hegel 13 years after he
stopped reading philosophy because made
in 44 he was reading just the economists
so you're saying karl marx is human
after all he's human he could be i would
love to have a beer with carl for a wine
for carl he's carl t
he's mr marks to me
maybe carl to me i'm afraid after all
issues yeah yeah you've had quite a
journey together so that's where after
hagel his interpretation of the dialect
comes in the form of background
foreground and background and then on
page
267 of the penguin edition of the
grundrusso
literally your memory one and a half
pages long footnote it's pretty hard to
forget because what when i when i did
this when i first read marks way way
back when i was uh how old was i 20
okay i tried to explain my explanation
of marx's use value exchange value stuff
to my colleagues in this philosophy
discussion room at sydney university
during a beautiful summer that we are
inside concrete
sandstone walls discussing marks
and i went to say look the use value
exchange value argument
can be applied to a machine what's the
exchange value for machines cost of
manufacturing what's its use value its
capacity to produce goods for sale
no relation between the two there will
be a gap a machine can be a source of
profit
now i said that and i got laughed at not
quite literally laughed at
so when i went back to university 13
years later to do my master's degree
i chose to read through and find in marx
where he first came across this insight
so i made up my first master's thesis
failed by the way and justifiably so
okay i was learning i didn't know the
level of
academic discourse necessary i had an
advisor who didn't understand what i was
writing he got me to write for his
new keynesian audience
and it was a mess and it got failed
so i got rid of it didn't get failed
because like why do you think it wasn't
a good thesis it was i didn't know the
level
it was written for an audience my my
supervisor thought that i should be
writing for
and it was a mess and so i met another
guy jeff jeff fishburne
uh as a lecturer at my new south wales
university and jeff was open-minded he
was not a conventional neoclassical
thinker
and i realized i'd throw out the half
that bill had got me to do
focused just on marx and so i decided to
read marx in chronological sequence
from his very first works of economics
which are called the economic and
philosophical manuscripts of 1844 and he
wrote those in a garrett in paris
after he'd been expelled from prussia
and so he decided to read uh the
having been an expert on philosophy and
regarded as the
towering intellect of of hegelian
philosophy and in prussia but driven out
because he was a radical he he ended up
writing a uh running a newspaper or
being writing for a newspaper and he was
reporting about the eviction of peasants
from the forests
taking away their feudal rights and so
this is where his passion for
economics and humanity came from and he
was a poet
as well i mean he wrote love poetry to
jenny von west west hale and that's his
first published works were pretty much
in poetry he was a rouse about he was
you know
a wild character we'd probably fight
like crazy i imagine if we met uh
over the beers i'm slightly even though
i can be um
i can get involved in an argument like
nobody's business no really no really
but i'm a bit more peaceful of
personality oh you think marx is
feistier than you he was feisty but uh
fasting with he could be arrogant like
i'm i've got an intellectual arrogance
up yeah come to accept that but there's
like a fundamental humility to you yeah
if you're saying marx is like he has ego
that's the case
yeah i'm guessing i mean i'm never going
to meet him well the beard says ego to
me the beard is huge yeah
okay so this is interesting you went
chronologically right through the
development of the human being through
his works yeah and i was trying to find
the point at which he discovered this
use value exchange value idea and it
occurs in a footnote on page 267 to 268
of the penguin edition of the gundressa
which his notes he was taking literally
not meant for publication literally
sitting at a stall inside the british
museum i think
reading all the classical authors in
chronological sequence and then somebody
throws hegel at him and suddenly he's
talking in hegelian terms and he
suddenly says is not uh because it's
whole value issues what is values is
exchange value use value how did they
relate to each other that's what he was
thinking about he said is not ex
use value which was left out of the
classical school a fundamental aspect of
the commodity
is there not a tension between the use
value and exchange value
just so we're clear in that context use
value is kind of the subjective thing
exchange value is the objective yeah and
marx was found a way to integrate the
two
but he was focused on
uh
labor being the only thing that can
generate both the user's value and the
exchange value but no
if you look at the classical school
they focus on exchange value objective
look at the neoclassical they focus upon
use value subjective or they call it
utility
so marx coming from the ricardian
tradition
basically dismissed the role of utility
and then when he reads hegel he's
suddenly starting to think in terms of
unities
and exchange value and use value is the
unity of the commodity
and he thinks well i can't ignore use
value
so rather than leaving it out completely
which is what ricardo and smith does
i've got to somehow bring it in and this
hegelian insight occurs to him and you
it's remarkable i really recommend
taking a look at the book even just to
look at that particular page because
what it would have been is it's shown as
a footnote but it would have been him
saying oh wow and his asterisk asterisk
is not you know
use value a fundamental aspect of the
unity of a commodity so in the notes you
see the discovery of an idea in the
human being it's beautiful the
integration of an idea and he actually
writes does this have significance in
economics question mark and then he
probably went home that night and like
that that idea changed yeah it changed
him completely okay and from that point
on his writing was completely different
but he still had this idea from the
ricardian days of saying that labour's
the only source of value using exclusive
argument to say there's something unique
about labor that explains why it's a
source of value but suddenly this
insight occurs to him and he thinks i
can get a positive derivation i can use
use value and exchange value
and the fact they're not related to each
other has a dialectical tension to
explain surplus value and that's what he
does so he goes from a negative
explanation of where value comes from to
a positive explanation on that page of
the grindrisa
you then triumphantly
uses it to explain why labor is a source
of value you buy it for its exchange
value you use its use value they're
unrelated the use value will be bigger
that's where profit comes from
then he does exactly the same thing for
machinery about 30 pages on
he says
uh it also has to be contemplated
which was not done before this is wrote
nice to himself by the way that's it's
written in really in a colloquial style
that the use value of a machine
significantly greater than its exchange
value he actually left out the word is
it's useful this is obviously to be
determined it'll be a translation into
english of the german i'm sure i don't
know i haven't i haven't seen the
original notes i'd love to see them but
uh he says he lives out the word is
he also has to be contemplated that the
exchange use value significantly greater
than its exchange value i.e that the
contribution of the machine to
production exceeds its depreciation
and that
was an insight which undermined
his explanation
for revolution
okay can you say that again the uh the
cost of production exceeds is
depreciation is that
okay can you linger on that i um well
what marx argued and you read this in
capital and i read this in capital when
i first saw
the contradiction in his own thought
he said that no matter how useful the
machine is whether it has
took 100 hours to make or cost 150
pounds it cannot under any circumstances
add more to production than 150 pounds
which
in his old exclusivist logic he could
justify
and which in his mod is his post 1857
argument is [ __ ]
can you steal man his case can we go to
the mine marks and thinking
if a machine costs
a hundred bucks
he can't be ever more
bring more value than a hundred bucks
but that contradicts his previous logic
because what do you see what he said is
uh you'd have a commodity is the
essential unity in capitalism
capitalism focuses upon the exchange
value
that pushes the use value into the
background and there's a tension between
the two
what that means is the exchange value of
the commodity sets its price
the use value is independent he called
them incommensurable he literally would
use the word
incommensurability between exchange
value and the use value whereas
neoclassicals make them commensurable so
saying exchange value and use value in
incommensurable that normally means that
exchange value is objective like the
number of hours it takes to make
something useful as subjective how
comfortable the chair is the fact that
you can sit in a chair
so that's incommensurability but when
you apply it in production
the exchange value of something is
objective it's how many hours it takes
to make a machine or how many hours it
takes to make the means of subsistence
for a worker the use value is also
objective you're making commodities for
sale
and the worker does six hours six hours
of work will make the the
means of subsistence for the worker but
the worker will work a 12-hour day
and the six hours becomes a gap
now that's incommensurability between
use value and exchange value of labor
but when you look at what he said about
no matter how long
it takes to make a machine or how many
pounds it costs he's saying they're
identical
and that's contradicting his own logic
well what's what's the use value of a
machine fact that it can produce
goods for sale exactly the same as the
worker
now what i've in my modern
reinterpretation of marx which brings in
my work on energy
i see both labor and machinery as a
means to harness energy
and produce useful work
and they can both do that in fact they
do it together it's a collective
enterprise
okay so
and we'll go to that so there's no
there's no fundamental difference from
exchange value and use value perspective
between a human and a machine and
therefore they're using the same logic
they can both be a source of surplus
yeah which is what marx contradicted
because
his explanation for where socialism
would come from is that only profit
comes from late profit comes only from
labor
over time will add more machinery than
labor that will mean a falling rate of
profit and therefore a tendency towards
socialism and what he did in that
insight in 1857 is contradict
his own idea about what would lead to
socialism
and he couldn't cope with it
you